[Music]
[Music]
you would have to be living under a rock
not to have heard about the ubisoft
forward event that was coming up
especially since the vast majority of
division content creators were given the
status of ubisoft partner and were able
to co-stream the event
this video will just be a summary of the
division portion and while i'm not going
to lie i was pretty disappointed in what
was shown there were a couple of
interesting pieces that came up
not a huge amount was said on the
division two daria recapped on season
nine in the new additions that came
along with it including countdown and
the expertise system
she moved on to talk about the
previously announced season 10 and 11
which will be released before the end of
the year
again no news here however if you look
at the bottom right corner we now have a
date for season 10. it's out in a couple
of days and before then the developers
will be going live on twitch to talk
about it
finally daria wrapped up by telling us
that work is well and truly begun on
year 5 content though she didn't give
any detail
so not a lot of news on the division 2 a
new game mode coming more legendary
difficulty missions and one of the
creepiest damn masks i've ever seen i
mean what the actual [ __ ] look at this
thing
community developer carrie started off
by confirming what had already been
assumed that heartland will be playing
out after the events of the early days
of the division two
creative director keith evans runs us
through what the team's been up to
hey everyone we're so excited to show
you heartland an all new stand-alone
adventure in the division universe
the teams poured their heart into this
game and we can't wait to share it with
you
welcome to silver creek
[Music]
i'm keith evans creative director in
heartland at red storm entertainment
we've been involved here at red storm
with the division going back before the
first game launched our partnership with
massive entertainment made some games
that we love we're so excited to bring
something new to fans of the franchise
heartland's a free-to-play survival
action shooter set in the division
universe that features streamlined
survival gameplay and a beautiful new
world to explore
you play as a division agent given the
task of protecting silver creek a small
town in middle america from enemy
factions rogue agents and a deadly
contamination this game ties directly
into the timeline and introduces all new
characters and story lines to the
franchise
heartland feels fresh and distinct while
still feeling at home alongside the
other amazing games in this universe
we can't wait to have you join us in
silver creek
[Music]
so heartland is a survival action
shooter where a division agent has been
tasked with protecting the small town of
silver creek but what i'm more happy to
hear about is that the game is
completely canon and ties in with the
existing storyline with new characters
containing their own stories
it's only a small thing to most but
given that i wasn't expecting this game
to be my sort of genre there is at least
something there that sounds right up my
alley
otherwise we've now been given some
pretty cool shots of the game including
the map up until now there really hasn't
been anything official shown
unfortunately they're still talking
about closed tests it's looking like
it's still quite a way off
the division resurgence was only
properly announced a little while ago so
it isn't surprising that they didn't
have much new to share however they did
have a new trailer featuring the dark
zone
let's
go oh
there is a closed beta coming out this
fall so it would appear that resurgence
is a little further along than heartland
so hopefully we'll be seeing this soon
maybe early next year
but this part cracks me up how are they
not hitting each other at that range
maybe they're shooting blanks or
something
and that's it in the almost one and a
half hour stream this is all we heard
about the division universe
given the number of announcements on the
division twitter account and how so many
content creators who are predominantly
devoted to the division were invited to
participate i was expecting a little
more
but we must look at it from a positive
side too
this is the first time in years that the
division has featured in any ubisoft
media so regardless of how limited it
was it's nice to see it getting some
sort of recognition
however what i did learn from this is
that it's a bloody good time to be an
assassin's creed fan
with 15 years of content to catch up on
i don't think it'll be something i'll be
tackling anytime soon
before i go i wanted to shout someone
out i expect that a lot of the people
who view my usual videos do so for the
immersive experience an expansion of the
division world that the game provides or
at least that's what i attempt to do i
don't watch a lot of other division
creators content as i feel it clouds my
own thoughts and judgment
however there is one that i'd like to
check in with periodically
story mode's channel is criminally
underrated
as the name suggests he focuses on short
form videos talking about every element
of the game
what i really enjoy is that he's pretty
much always in character and regardless
of how i'm feeling about it at the time
he has this ability to drag me back into
the game
the immersion he brings even to the most
mundane topic must be credited
please check him out and say hi
i haven't thought of how yet but i'm
really keen on working with them in the
future
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh